I have to look I have to bring this up
because we were both at the Christmas
tree lighting I was most excited like
they were like will you host the show I
was like sure yeah I love it like I love
Christmas I was most
excited this is me dancing singing every
Dam word I'm not kidding I wore my
sister out with your song at
Thanksgiving like it came out in October
and I was I literally told my I was like
please get her on the show I was like I
this is the DJ play Christmas song I'm
going say it fight on it it's the
greatest Christmas song to come out
since all I want for Christmas is
you it's the greatest contemporary
Christmas song to come out like I I love
it so much it makes me so happy I'm not
I'm not kidding I have sent videos to my
friends like Blake Shelton and Nile
they've I've hit them up so much with
videos of me just singing your song good
yeah it's so good but you know what
that's what I wanted that's the reason I
never made a Christmas album before was
because I couldn't find in my mind I
couldn't find a way to put myself into
to a share Christmas you know so then I
found these I found my a girl I've known
since I she was four years old sent me
that song and and um and I didn't even
know it was her Sarah Hudson four years
old Sarah Hudson big writer whatever
yeah so I got that and then all of a
sudden I started to kind of not you know
how your mind is thinking but you're not
aware of it but so then I thought about
doing the song with Darlene oh I did not
know the backstory on that that you
originally did I didn't know that no I
love that you sing the backgrounds and
then you all twisted it and now she's
singing it with you no and I because I
wasn't going to do it unless she wanted
to sing it with me because somehow it
just wouldn't have been right but on
this one of the songs on my album
Darlene Love who sings baby please come
home and everybody knows it blah blah
blah blah when I was 17 I did the
background on it so when we came
together with it I never knew this
really it it was really good I never
knew that I think I heard you say that
I'm fing and I was like I never knew
that I I think that's incredible no but
how would you know this like nameless
faceless little kid get in the back but
move Shar could you just step back Shar
could you just step back Shar could you
just sing a little softer no but that oh
that's been my thing the whole life
they're like you're too loud blend
you're
[Music]
excited
[Applause]
thank you guys y have a great night I'm
going
home